hi guys dr. Berg here in this video I
want to share with you the real cause of
gall stones now a lot of times when you
go to the doctor if you have gall stones
they're going to just remove the
gallbladder without explaining what
caused them in the first place right
well gall stones are really cholesterol
stones and it's not caused by consuming
too much cholesterol it's caused because
you don't have enough bile to break down
the cholesterol stones so what is bile
bile is made by the liver it's stored in
the gallbladder that is just the sack to
help you dissolve fats in your diet okay
so I'm going to I'm going to demonstrate
this so here we have a little container
of fat okay this is oil this is like you
just ate some fatty foods right and here
we have detergent this is the bile so if
we mix the detergent with the oil don't
try this at home
okay and this is what the gallbladder
does okay you just shake a little bit
well look at that so basically the
detergent dissolved the oil into small
particles that's called a multiplication
okay so the bile dissolves the fat and
then the pancreas over here underneath
your left ribcage sends another thing in
there called lipase that's an enzyme for
fats that takes it one step further and
dissolves it into real small particles
so you can start absorbing it to the
intestines or the liver okay but
basically the gallbladder breaks down
fats and so we need bile but really a
low bile problem is a is the symptom of
something else so it could be either a
symptom of excess estrogen and that's
why women they go through pregnancy or
they have high levels of estrogen can
get gall stones as well or if they're
taking birth control pills or if they're
taking hormone replacement therapy right
excessive cortisol can also cause gall
stones that's stress excessive insulin
can cause gall stones as well
because it depletes the bile reserve and
that's why a lot of diabetics get golf
stones right well it's an estrogen I'm
sorry it's an insulin problem too much
insulin depletes the bile low fatty
diets can also cause about efficiency
why because the thing that triggers the
release of bile is saturated fats so if
you don't eat enough fats especially
saturated fats your body is just not
going to make the bile and then you're
going to have a less amount and you
could get gall stones from that
constipation could also be another cause
because it backs up the whole thing but
then also it could go low bile can cause
constipation because by lubricates the
colon so it could be a little bit of a
you know the chicken of the egg we don't
know which one it is so those are some
simple solutions so how do we dissolve
the stones well you take you increase
your bile you figure out which one this
is you correct the diet if it's too much
sugar too much stress too much estrogen
you correct that in the meantime you can
dissolve the stone by taking the bile
salt
it's a concentrate the one that I use is
called gall bladder formula and it not
only has purified bile salts but it has
stone root which is an herb that
dissolves stones plus I added in there a
bunch of enzymes and acidify errs to
really help the stomach release your own
bile so you can actually produce more
okay so if you're interested check the
link below okay in summary you want to
know the cause of your gall stones so
you can actually prevent a problem down
the road so even if they remove the gall
bladder
the cause is still there it can create
liver stones in fact so you may not have
a gallstone but now you get a liver
stone alright well thanks for watching
I'll see you the next video hey guys
thank you so much for watching please
click the subscribe button and I will
see you in the next video